well the better half of the sink feel
sinkfield corporation that is dr. Jeanne
sing feel welcome to the show for the
first time as a matter of fact we met
your husband blab his mouth all the time
on the show and finally we get to you on
we are we've seen the work you've done
with the boy scouts and your husband
mentioned it just a few moments ago tell
us more about why you thought this was
important to do and how it came into
being well I was trying to people here
and I was saying we should have a chest
merit badge because we had we blows and
Cub Scouts and they said they had been
trying for 40 years and they told me
that I couldn't do it generous thing to
tell us Inc feel Sara Lee yeah and so I
thought okay so I talked to people
nobody knew how to do it nobody in the
scouting so I called it one of my
friends and she was on the national
committee to approve new merit badges so
we had a nice little conversation I
offered to sponsor the launch and bingo
we have a chest merit badge now you have
a hundred thousand voice cause that's an
incredible number and not only that is
they have to teach another skid how to
play chess so you need so it's two
hundred thousand and then the we're
doing things like my council has a boy
scout camp every summer they have a
chess tournament every summer so you can
be the best boy scout at your week at
summer camp you get a little trophy in
there like yes you're successful and
then you go out and play chess yes
that's pretty extraordinary could you
have imagined that this was what was
going to happen when your husband when
Rex said you know what I think I want to
sponsor some chests and say Louis did
you think this would happen I remember
wafer he first started playing chess to
get my permission right well we're
married right that's what husband's do
and and I thought to myself you know he
was going to go to a few tournaments I
said to myself how expensive could it be
okay same with this it's like how
expensive could it be it's very
expensive and just when I think he's
sort of like okay we're good i can put
it on the budget we figure out what
we're doing and we get the sink filled
cup right and then okay well okay we've
got there we're just there
and then it's like Oh a grand tour okay
so sometimes you're just afraid to ask
right well you're used to his big
visions you know the world chess hall of
fame is another one you've had many
convert contributions to that including
a music series I know that you're near
and dear to the idea of music yourself
yeah some of the music you've been
hearing on the thing as part of this
thing we're doing called a trying to
make Missouri of mcafee musical
composition because it's always a
bennett a city of music here and so we
you know are crying we're going to have
a concert in the spring you're going to
love is called the sound of art but it's
going to be about chess they're going to
be five brand-new pieces written by
young composers about chest I thought
you're gonna say five brand-new chess
pieces have enough trouble following
these boards these also we have things
like some of the music that's being
played one is I think st. Louis Reds and
people having real positive comments
about the music in the intermission and
then one of them had the funniest
comment I think it was a Jennifer who
said something and it was she said they
said that person said it was too what
would you say to active too aggressive
and I'm thinking I think of chess is
being aggressive and you're thinking the
music is too aggressive to match a chess
tournament you people have their own
images of the game well we really
appreciate all the work that you have
done and your continued support of this
fine art of chess and we think we ask
one thing I have a goal I want to do in
the next two years I want to have a
national team Boy Scout chess tournament
I want to have teams of Boy Scouts
across the country play with each other
teams and have the best teams come here
to st. Louis to find the best boy scout
team and chest so if you're out there in
America and you play chess and your boy
scout go form a team send us an email
and we'll get we'll see who the best boy
scout chess players are in America
fantastic I don't doubt it's going to
happen it's a done deal done deal well
thank you so much Jeannie Singh field on
the wonderful dr. Jeanne Singh field who
can
used to have big visions for chess in
the United States